alors comment me trouvez vous tuera vie
saura vous est si belle match amical
aura encore plus heureux de vous offrir
ce 30 mai ce qui est du snap je ne sais
pas si je peux accepter un aussi beau
cadeau ne soyez pas gêner ma chère amie
ce matin encore je ne connaissais pas
l'existence est en voulant ranger mon
grenier que je les trouvais par hasard
bien rangés dans une boîte au fond d'une
baleine et si vous me la refuse est bien
la seule ressource sera de la remettre
pour toujours au fond de cette vieille
malle et bien jacques cette avance julie
raison d'accepter cette robe va mieux
merci
bonsoir
un troupeau de vaches qui passe
non monsieur du snob pour que ces
questions tout en déclenchant à 2009
c'est l'émotion oui
vous êtes trop émotif
mademoiselle julie pour un beau
déguisement c'est un beau déguisement
pour sûr c'est pourtant pas carnaval
voilà brutalement ramené à la réalité en
face et saturn mais ce n'est pas un
déguisement mais c'est une très jolie
rang oui qui me vient de ma grand-mère
monsieur robert et j'ai voulu vexer
personne
annoncer à quoi
vous n'avez pas entendu argent répète
tout ce que c'est que cette horreur que
julie porte sur le dos
mais c'est une robe ravisseurs
elle est entièrement cousu à la main l
immense francs mais c'est moi qui lui
offert un joli ah bah ça ne m'étonne pas
nine deux émirs comeau a bear et julie
est bien en forme blue jeans avec des
branches et
tais toi j me va mais non je crois que
j'ai compris casimir à sa canne et son
chapeau parce que je lui avais promis
danser avec lui alors il est furieux de
voir habillée romaine au plus de
répétitions écoute casimir je file
changer mes chaussures mais je danserai
avec la robe très bien ça ira comme ça
mon papa l'instant je vais aller devant
une glace ajuster mon chapeau pour
l'avoir sur l'oeil
sur la route vous avez affaire à julie
elle est très belle 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 qui
valorise vous que tu crois que ça
continue ainsi à masina schwyz 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
3 à mes bons amis je suis en train de
vous préparer une surprise il s'est
repris j'espère que ça ne fait pas mal
raw pour surnom au casimir j'ai remarqué
depuis un certain temps que vous dansiez
toujours le même pas ah oui ça n'est pas
vraiment varié enfin alors j'ai décidé
de devenir
convaincant et quoi que ce soit grave
casimir c'est celui ou celle qui qui qui
inventent n'est pas un code d'une
nouvelle danse pour vous avez fait de
nouveau faim oui oui ici c'est une bonne
surprise pareil bon vous allez me suivre
venez vous derrière moi
mettez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
il
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors pensez vous moi
nous ne voyons pas tout à fait notre
danse comme ça un facteur non
je suis gay chine
merci quand même facteur pour sûr il ne
me reste plus que continuer ma tournée
alors il vaut mieux fort
alors quasi mais ça y est tu
préfère encore ce caspien déchire la
demie réjouissez vous mais trouver une
chorégraphie peu votre dos tient à coeur
joie ne se fait pas 10 rebonds alors
mettez-vous en place comme sa musique là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
on
[Musique]
m
ouais ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors qu'en pensez vous
ça ça ne va pas du tout oui bon j'aurais
dû m'en douter je suis trop bonne avance
sur mon temps vous pouvez pas comprendre
mon message artistique est très bien je
reviendrai dans quelques années
quand elle susceptibilités
bombe à casimir nous allons faire notre
nouvelle chorégraphie est maintenant
d'accord tu seras cette fois vers 10
heures du matin attendez attendez quoi
non plus en jaune très bonne surprise
non ça suffit à les nantais ça ça suffit
comme ça nous commençons à en avoir
assez tu comprends voilà maintenant nous
ne voulons plus de chorégraphes à
l'internet
qu'est ce qui leur prend je voulais
juste leur annoncer que j'avais réussi
un examen
je crois que cette fois nous allons
pouvoir aller très casimir
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hop
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh